il y a un an dans le cadre de la loi 3DS
le Parlement a voté les modalités pour
la rétrocession des 250 000 hectares à
la collectivité territoriale de Guyane
et aux communes de Guyane nous sommes
toujours en attente de décret
d'application toutefois la question sur
un débattu très prochainement dans le
comité interministériel des Outre-mer le
siome donc moi la question que je veux
poser pouvez-vous me dire si la
collectivité est territoriale de Guyane
se projette déjà dans la redistribution
du foncier aussi quel pourcentage sera
consacré à l'agriculture et monsieur le
Président de la Chambre de l'agriculture
depuis toujours les jeunes agriculteurs
éprouvent le plus grand mal à
s'installer pourtant la Guyane
ambitionne depuis longtemps d'améliorer
son auto suffisance alimentaire et
depuis mon élection au Sénat je suis
très souvent interpellé par eux je suis
régulièrement allée à la rencontre des
jeunes agriculteurs et les problèmes
reviennent toujours les mêmes lourdeur
administrative difficulté à obtenir
certaines aides installations des zones
éloignées dans des zones éloignées de
tout parfois directement forêt primaire
et puis on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers
temps des pistes forestières qui ne sont
pas praticables en temps de pluie face à
cette situation beaucoup préfèrent jeter
les pages ou mettre fin à leur jour il
serait important que la Chambre
d'Agriculture et l'État et l'État puisse
apporter un meilleur soutien à nos
jeunes agriculteurs quelle solution
avez-vous hormis bien sûr celle des
finances puisque vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure mais pour le moment il y a pas
de finance que faites-vous au niveau de
la Chambre d'Agriculture pour aider les
jeunes agriculteurs
nous avons sur cette 250 000 hectares
pour le moment aucun écrit en tout cas
aucune décision définitive
ceci dit nous avons accueilli pas mal de
demandes
provenant notamment de certaines
collectivités qui ont besoin de foncier
mais également nous sommes en attente
vous le pensez bien de cette création de
la SAFER qui soit bien mise en place
justement pour pouvoir
justement savoir comment on distribue ce
foncier c'est vrai que vous avez raison
on a la
sénatrice sur
l'enclavement des exploitations
agricoles et les problèmes que nous
avons dû récemment en Guyane ça avec la
cycle social nous sommes en
pleine travail dessus et nous nous avons
même avant que
ces événements soient arrivés soit
nous avons déjà commencé à travailler
ensemble pour assurer ce réseau de
désenclavagement des acteurs
concernant l'installation des jeux
acteurs alors nous avons actuellement
depuis un moment nous avons travaillé je
commence à travailler déjà la chambre à
travailler déjà avec la CAF parce que en
Guyane tout à l'heure nous avons cité
que
les
éditeur aujourd'hui ils servent ils se
servent pour financer leurs projets et
souvent les agriculteurs les jeunes
acteurs sont obligés d'aller travailler
ailleurs pour pouvoir assurer un petit
revenu pour qu'il puisse travailler à
100% sur son exploitation nous avons
travaillé avec
la CAF
si c'est possible de mettre en place un
petit revenu pour garantir que le
directeur puisse travailler à 100% sur
son exploitation alors je reviens
peut-être sur un aspect que vous
soulevez madame la sénatrice les pistes
forestières vous évoquez les pistes
forestières qui est ou qui est encore
une particularité très guyanaise il se
pose donc très vite le sujet de
l'entretien de ces desserts de ces
routes et forcément là on est je pense
de façon historique un petit peu dans un
improglio entre les aspects juridiques
puisque l'État reste propriétaire de ses
emprises de desserte qui quand même
alimenter ou permettre l'accès à des
exploitations et des habitants d'une
commune il y a certainement un travail à
faire avec les collectivités
moi
il nous semble côté état que c'est bien
l'autorité communale qui à terme doit
devenir peut-être
reprendre ces infrastructures on parle
après évidemment d'amener des réseaux
des des services comme l'eau potable
comme l'électricité bon en France
effectivement la compétence en termes
d'eau potable et de toute façon
communale voir intercommunale mais là
concernant la voirie qui est le
préalable pour aller dans des dans des
zones
agricoles il y a effectivement un
travail en commun et certainement
plan directeur peut-être à mettre en
place à l'échelle des communes voir des
EPCI pour bien
identifier le niveau juridique de toutes
ces voix